we will now talk about the efforts to
develop an HIV vaccine that started
immediately after scientists identify
the AIDS patient zero and constructed
the first HIV transmission tree
however developing canals works in
proved to be a difficult task in 1994
Bill Clinton famously unknowns that it
is no longer question of whether we can
develop an AIDS vaccine it is simply a
question of when
however today they still don't have an
HIV vaccine to explain why it is so
difficult to develop an HIV vaccine
let's consider how the HIV virus evades
the immune system the shell of the HIV
virus is covered by the envelope
proteins and the idea of an HIV vaccine
is to stimulate the immune system so
that it is able to recognize envelope
proteins as foreign and to destroy them
this approach however failed because the
HIV envelope proteins are extremely
variable there are many HIV subtypes
even in a single individual the HIV
population evolves so fast that it evade
the immune system and results in many
HIV subtypes HIV strains from different
patients are so diverge that they
require different drug cartels us
raising the challenge of classifying HIV
subject and one of these subtypes may
become fast replicating and deadly it
happens when HIV tricks human cells into
fusing all these neighboring cells such
fusion creates a giant multi cell that
allows the virus to kill many cells at
once imagine that you are a doctor
wants to figure out whether your HIV
patient has developed a fast replicated
subtype what would you do today you can
determine sequences of dozens and even
hundreds of various HIV genomes
circulating in a patient's but how would
you figure out whether some of them
represent a fast replicating subtype a
difficult machine learning problems
biologists figured out that if you shift
any line all these HIV sequences in a
specific way then an interesting pattern
emerges fast replicating HIV genomes
have amino acid arginine or lysine at
positions eleven and twenty five of the
envelope proteins allowing conductor to
diagnose this subtype but how do you
know what is the correct alignment that
reveals the 1125 row do you see an
interesting pattern in these three
sequences probably not but if I line
them the string algorithm in red will
emerge you probably don't see any
similarities between identifying first
replicating HIV viruses and the speech
recognition wait until we cover the
Viterbi algorithm and see why the hidden
Markov models have turned into one of
the most popular algorithmic techniques
in machine learning with wide ranging
applications next I will describe a
recent outbreak of an e coli killer
strain and will ask you to come up with
is a problem formulation that would help
doctors to stop this outbreak